greetings from podcast Ville its Monday
the 22nd wash your mother-fucking muffle
and powder your dick it's gonna be a
good week the Church of what's happened
now is brought to you by manscape you
ever look at your [ __ ] helmet and it
looks like a [ __ ] haunted mansion is
surrounding it with all the air and all
the [ __ ] funk well listen it ends now
it's time to trim your balls if summer
time you want to keep your [ __ ] nuts
fresh and your [ __ ] dipstick on fire
I'm here to help you you ready for this
manscaped
they got precision tools for the Family
Jewels manscaped
has redesigned the electric razor so no
more [ __ ] stressing out no more
anxiety no more [ __ ] what I'm gonna
do is this the church family the
listeners can get 20% off your first
order when you use promo code church at
manscape calm and if you order the
perfect package don't throw in a free
travel bag when you use code Church
that's manscape calm use promo code
church for 20% off your first order a
it's [ __ ] summertime keep your balls
clean the church is also brought to you
by on it listen for all your supplements
on is the way to go between the shroom
tech the Alpha brain the protein power
of the jerky go to honor calm right now
and on the way out press in church and
get 10% off you ought to deliver it
right to your house the church is also
brought to you by CBD Lyon listen the
[ __ ] search is over I'm bringing you
the [ __ ] the thing that's gonna keep
your ticket for the rest of your life
CBD line you can smoke in vapors you
could take the tensions you could take
the gummi bears go to CBD line right now
and press in church and get 20% off your
first daughter
it's Monday this song like kill you
about the song come pop it came out with
Pulp Fiction yeah and all those little
[ __ ] kids mother jumping up and
thinking they heard it for the first
song came out when I was in the sixth
grade
really I still remember going like dance
you know yes like you dance uh-huh and
like dancing for this and losing your
mind with high heels and bell-bottoms is
she trying to get a chain I were like
one chain with uh with Mary on it
the mother Mary I thought it was cool I
was always like trying to get in get the
chain like lined up just inside the the
collar so it looked cool so the girls
would see it it's so good
but you contribute yes sir no city at
all Jersey born and bred Jersey born and
born and Passaic okay at Saint Mary's
Hospital know it well and then moved to
Park Ridge Park Ridge then I moved right
next door to will cliff lake and that
was it pirates work in the city my
father did my father work fun city for a
while yeah the Train of the bus
uh I think he drove did he know you
would dry but he didn't do it the whole
way like then he then he started working
in North Jersey after that like it kind
of shifted he was in sales he sold like
early like communication stuff and and
then he was always like commuting around
there he had one commute where he got a
job in happauge new york which is out
and want like the ass and the Long
Island all the way from Jersey all the
way to Long Island he did that for like
a year and that was brutal
I remember they tried to call me a
couple years ago we got a great gig for
you and everybody goes you know it's
like to Jersey Shore now yeah the kids
yeah do you leave the night before right
like you leave that when the bars closed
yeah whoo you went straight down the
shore [ __ ] lit that's didn't stop for
tolls just went through no cameras
nobody stopping you know nothing and you
can't but you cruise the whole way we
cruise the whole way here now it's
bumper-to-bumper
I remember how to talk Sebastian on it
like
Ashley had a talkback he was doing
Vinnie's fun house down the Jersey Shore
he said get me and my wife was standing
a cynical are you [ __ ] crazy yeah I
go this a hotel dumb because you have I
went last time but there was sand
everywhere I go with on Fridays and
Saturdays you ain't driving back
Saturday late wouldn't be too bad
because it's all the renters come in
Saturday morning so Friday night and
Saturday morning are brutal and then
once that's over then you can kind of do
it but we were in Long Beach Island
my family had a place there forever how
beautiful that was white oh my god we
would kids anywhere else with savages
LBI was white people I did a little
chubby girl from LBI because the house
is similar edge it was so the beach with
us melody Mello between seaside in you
and you can see the water turn yellow in
Seaside with that Guido juice there's no
boardwalk there's like very low liquor
sale always it no it's the same it's
exactly the same it took a real hit
during sandy during Hurricane sandy the
ocean met the bay and I remember I was
in New York with my power off in the
village living there during sandy and we
had no power but I was able to like
generator it and went online and saw a
picture from a helicopter of Long Beach
Island which is where I've been going
since I was a you know four years old
and it Joey I didn't think you would
ever come back it looked like this is
just gone it was just water and like the
tops of homes and the water towers stuff
like that and you I really thought well
that's that's it but then a you know
it's subsided and now it's okay it's you
know they have to really build up the
beach and do all this other stuff but
it's uh it's just the same as it always
was when I was a kid it was LBI and then
there was one a little deeper that was
that's where class went right that's
where people would class well yeah well
there's like Avalon and no came a Cape
May yeah that's when I people went
nobody held on the street
little [ __ ] you know you had to drive
south though that was the thing the
further you drove from the city nicer
God because you know it was a you know
you're drinking him in the city just go
to whatever Beach is closed but if you
want to take your family you have to put
like two and a half hour drive in and
then it started to like kind of calm
down but uh there's the one what's the
one that doesn't sell alcohol a between
Atlantic City and I remember which I
don't remember the name of it there was
someplace space in the name but yeah a
lot of times are the smart they go we
don't want that corruption that's the
thing in town in the summer yeah right
exactly
I remember being a kid and going I
wasn't even noticing men doing yeah as
we'd be parking on side streets in front
of people's houses walking two blocks
with a case of beer yelling with the
[ __ ] yeah and I would feel bad I was
always a gentleman
yeah my mom's are people if they sit a
little bit you're like you don't even
realize that when you're again when
you're a kid it's and I started like I
did the whole short tape thing yeah like
I started with like the first you go to
the shore that's by yes this is very
Park yeah this is the beach next to it
no bueno where did you could wait where
were you living
I was living in Hudson County the town
called North Bergen that's North America
next to Union City and yell Balkan right
yeah yeah water I'm what they call a
real deal tunnel right yes yes my
[ __ ] life yeah but the shore like we
live in California Brad I don't go I
don't go down there anyone see you with
the baby instead of each then we go to
Orange County and you know don't you
miss it like I mean it's in a weird
we're in California and we're not at the
beach like in he lived in New Jersey and
urine at the beach all the time isn't it
strange I you know California is very
deceiving because when you grew up on
the East Coast its or used all these
they don't show you going they'll never
show you the valley you always show you
know not even they always show you
Redondo Beach yeah it's immaculate
I can't wait to move to California gonna
show you Long Beach you know people are
bicycles and gangbangers you [ __ ] at
each other yeah then I'll show you I
know you're all this they show you the
beach yeah so I've been coming here
since hours eight nine why cuz my
uncle's here and mother's brother had a
bar here he came from Cuba went to New
York City didn't like it and came here
here he came here as a maintenance man
from an actor he had a TV show and told
me the guys name he's a popular guy he
met him in New York he lived in the
building right the guy took a liking for
him said if you want to live in the
guest house I got a TV show so the TV
show lasted one season he got cancelled
and my uncle said woman had to come back
from New York right so he met a check
you open the bar blah I still remember
coming out of your first time yeah well
like I was very disappointed yeah
there's anyway I was kicking the Dodger
game was on fire well he was been Glen
there would be looks like Jersey yeah
not the good parts you know you gonna
lay cash in the Burbank Boulevard yeah
they haven't done construction there
since 1950 Bob Hope yeah the more north
you go you know put the [ __ ] these
people been doing on me for 35,000 years
this looks like a [ __ ] die and it's
all concrete and the light is so harsh
harsh I can't tell if my sunglasses are
on or off it's bright and just you know
like tire shops and I know it's dirty to
me is sandy look it just looks like
there's a big dust storm or something
and you like immediately think like
where are the rich people and you're
like oh they're in Beverly Hills they're
in Malibu they're in uh you know Laguna
and you're like oh that's the nice peach
and that's where we're not going I wait
I take like the girls Arlington Beach
there's a whole town man has a bridge to
the [ __ ] beach they give you thanks I
was free I'm brauch all included nice
it's your own little private beach and
it's all for kids that's great
at night the kids have a movie then cook
hot dogs s'mores yeah yeah yeah they
give marshmallows we have three days of
paradise and they got to dari please not
one
breanne who [ __ ] fairy Queens we were
there New Year's Eve because there's not
a lot of dairy queens out here no
there's not it's at such a
disappointment when I'm in Montvale
there was a Dairy Queen that our
football coach owned oh ah and it was a
drive it was like the only thing it was
on it wasn't a strip mall it was just a
Dairy Queen yeah in a parking lot and
you just pull up and there's be cute
girls and your friends and you just get
a Slurpee I mean a a blizzard and hang
out on your car uh who was a dream and
then we came out here
no Dairy Queen's he's very hard to find
what nice purple blizzard would have no
ice cream float now [ __ ] in the
summer I like the ring finger you drink
all the grape juice you mix the ice
cream with the ice like a Puerto Rican
[Music]
look at me I'm a [ __ ] Davone I would
go in there medium hot fudge and a
[ __ ] great thing with a float and
there's in a best way like grape so it
was like a slice
they don't have mr. miss yeah but no
miss T the right thing put a blob of the
ice cream ice cream oh my god the great
I like the green green all the way I'm a
Carvel guy are you I'm a big trip and
the car better than Dairy Queen yeah I'm
a big green world to New York City when
it comes to car buy the cake on my
birthday cuz there's some of those out
here in my house there's a clog Oh cake
every birthday my wife me and the baby
get caught up cakes every background
which cookie which cookie you make your
wife get it - yeah no choice it's
tradition it's Cuban tradition
you gotta go yeah I would get a double
cone vanilla chocolate with college
sprinkles and whipped cream and
chocolate shake thin and then
Kevon I would dip the ice cream how are
you 1983 I drank the Congo milkshake
every day every day every day on the way
home from Fort Lee the cliffside stop
Eddie gray Eddie Burke yeah biingo
eclipse
I knew would know Cliffside Park border
with Fort Lee
there wasn't loadout Shipe there was a
detail shot huh huh and that was Eddie
Murphy's one brother because they were
living in Eclipse and right on the
corner was a Carvel and I was an
open-mic in 93 when did you start 91 in
91 in Denver though Oh in Denver Denver
how that happened I was living in
Boulder yeah then I would back that
makes no sense so yeah now we're back to
New York to see what the real scene was
right because I started 93 sorry I just
miss ya how you should do a New York
Comedy Club with Mikey Bocchetti that
was my first spot in New York County
don't say yeah yeah just each other
somewhere yes yeah 90 what grade you
start you went to college I went to
college degree communication no theater
yeah okay you did all that I didn't my
degree wasn't in theater but I went to
the school I was an athlete my whole
life and I specifically went to rider
college in New Jersey because it didn't
have football my father was like maybe
you'll play Division three and keep
going and I was like I'm done I've been
I've been playing football since I was
kindergarten and this is 12 years later
I'm I've done it I'm done
how do you feel how do I feel I believe
they're doing all this [ __ ] with for
like football numbers I find off the
board yeah I know I'm up with a bunch of
like I watch that on HBO Sports numbers
it down and they're trying to even get
girls to play football no to be punters
uh-huh and field goal kickers because
the numbers are so down in football yeah
I know well everybody's so scared of the
head trauma and all this but I you know
I took a lot of hits to the head but it
depends where you put like you know I
was in suburbia it was you know a lot of
white kids not you not not many of those
monsters
Aska kills that's yeah it was a good say
[ __ ] that towards the end you play
brick you say yeah well you when Passaic
came to play us in like a scrimmage and
stuff it was like alright if I'm getting
hit by that guy that was like Hayward
iron head regular yeah I play well yeah
he plays yeah and that guy was like a
man playing among boys there was a kid
in brick wall people duska he put the
head didn't even fit the helmet he was
killing yeah like if you got hit by guys
like that I could see it being a problem
but when you're just bouncing around
other kids from Bergen County you're
probably not gonna be in danger and I
took some hits I remember like you know
wasabi behind the eyes kind of like poof
but uh it was fine I think it's fine my
father though who played all the time
did he really play he was like a big
time in Clifton New Jersey and he was
like state championship like this is
when high school football like the
entire town was out with their hats
their fedoras and there's trench coats
watching kids play football thousands of
people watching these kids play football
and he was like the star and he did it
and loved it and it was like a you know
he's still known in Jersey what's his
day Tom papa really yeah and he didn't
want my nephews to play because his
shoulders messed up and his knees messed
up and it's just any you can't lift his
arm and it was just like he talked to my
nephew I mean this was his life and he
even coached me in high school he came
into the program to be a part of it and
he was like and then in the aches
started settling in and he's like I
don't know if you should play football
you know it's weird because I did after
I watched that HBO sport thing about a
month ago was I'm right after the Super
Bowl right around the time of the Jambo
I did an inventory of the kids that were
number one just to let you know and you
could we can look this up right now in
1978 my high school got ranked number
one on the East Coast Wow
where was we played Snider and seven to
six we beat Snider and they had walking
Lee actually he went on to the Minnesota
Vikings and who won against the Raiders
on a Monday Night Football interception
he was a
Wow so I will school you North Bergen
high well now we're gonna crush me yeah
you know those kids have played together
since they were five like those those
plays they taught you in PE yeah only
got built up so by the time you got the
high school you knew this guy
yeah this guy yeah all those kids I hang
out with will always go remember this in
my I was living in New York at the time
Wow so I didn't play another that peewee
football [ __ ] I played injures in Union
City they had a semi-pro no wait Lee I
did that for two years when I was in
Catholic school uh-huh
I would do that around with it the games
were Saturday isn't it they would
attract this rec they told me I didn't
need to practice right that and it was
okay by the time I got to high school I
was a basketball player and I was a
basketball player so it's a no football
no I worked my freshman year they wanted
me to play freshman year I showed up i
plied did the scrimmage against
Dickinson uh-huh we're blondie winter
where he's had a fight broke out and I
was so you know I had dedicated my life
to basketball yeah yeah five star
basketball boos down at violin what
position I was a forward for it
I was a forward and then my freshman
year I didn't start it cracked me
I heard the drugs my mother died that
was the end of my like I still the last
night I was watching the insert mm oh
yeah and some and some kid goes like you
and 79th Street taking it to the hoop I
was really good yeah oh wow the coach
didn't like me just didn't like really
but he cracked me for years I thought
about going back and shoot them like
shoot this guy yeah yeah yeah he has
impact so when I was done with it I I
was like a rider college had no football
they got kicked out of the league for
something and I was like I'm going here
cuz they had theater and I always wanted
to be a comedian since I was a kid
but I my parents wanted me to get a
degree so I'm in school going for this
communications degree but I'm
immediately to the theater department
and started auditioning and taking
classes and I got in the plays and that
was it all my time was spent
acting in the theater and I got the
degree and and got through it but that's
when I realized this is my life my life
is not even hanging with friends as much
as I'm there would be parties and the
stuff spring break oh no acting acting
acting theatre hanging out there just
living you know cuz you know to live
this life you can't live the life
everyone else lives you're not gonna be
partying on the weekends you're gonna be
performing on the weekends you're not
gonna be watching the big game on a
Thursday night cuz you'll be in a club
you have to have that mindset that you
don't belong you don't go to the rhythm
of the rest of the world and that's what
in when I was going to theater in
college that's when it that shift
happened I remember standing in awawa in
in Lawrenceville New Jersey on a Friday
night when all my friends were having
this rager party and I just came from
the from my show and I'm getting a
turkey sandwich at the Wawa and thinking
I'm so much happier doing this than
partying with those guys at the at the
party and that's when I knew okay I'm
built for this I can go I can go do this
you were active at that age I dreamt of
acting yeah I didn't know about acting
classes I thought you would bartend in
the city right and then some director
would come in and go hey which happened
a lot when we was when we were kids the
end Willis and there was somebody else
yeah Mickey Rourke Mickey Rourke answer
people so I thought that was the way in
and I got a job in Manhattan
nobody ever [ __ ] talk to me about
dnaa oh right he was the 7/7 I worked at
the Sheridan Center for 18 months
[Laughter]
thinking this is I'm an actor now you
know I really don't know but no you bump
into somebody who's school Ginn says
well yeah take an acting class and when
I was in Colorado right before I got put
away my roommate had a friend that was a
camera guy right and I would thank you
yeah like talk to your buddy dog yeah we
need to do the movie movie se7en awesome
well and I'm like what do we have to do
to get in the movie so I thought it was
just yeah we picked you is it funny
though like these like
my little journey in your little journey
and then we ended up in a movie together
right oops - OH - yeah in one of the
worst movies of all time analyze that
god bless hey how great was he to work
with oh how do just it just being there
I know the bad I'm not even talking
about the there Rotella rain less the
rainbows yeah Harold Raymond he set me
straight
yeah he set me straight really yeah I
tried to pick his brain a little bit not
very open cuz I had a reference uh he
was dear friends with a friend of mine
in Chicago so my friend took me to a
restaurant one night on Monday night it
was called hold the wall huh on the
north side of Chicago is a little place
and he Ramos went down yeah so well then
he goes come Monday we do the riddles
take a [ __ ] cab again I'm like I'm
making 500 a week yeah you know I gotta
take a cab from a North Shore 90 yeah he
left the but there you go you're right I
went up there sat down yeah
sure enough he came in he was oh you
have a nice look alibi so when I went in
for a movie for Georgia and walkins
partner out here uh-huh I went in
further the what about the guy from the
gun show that was the CIA oh yeah that's
good yeah yeah v8 uh-huh you know
Kinnear yes and she said to me you're
not good for this one but you're good
for my next movie
and she goes what and I may believe him
like what's your next movie she goes
analyze that it's the script they're
working on it now what I want you to do
is send me everything you got all the
real I had stand-up real friend laugh
factory with no sound yeah you know I
had like the cowboy short films and then
I got this film called the mezzo
brothers the reason one of the reasons
big [ __ ] quit the soprano he got kind
of fired and left was because he took a
deal from ABC in two thousand I'm sorry
can I interrupt you for a second you
know it's so funny about that
I was like no he think he they killed
him and pushed him off the boat like in
my mind that show was so good it's that
good that I didn't even think of show
business
of course he something happened with his
contract and he got fired
whenever whenever you would ask yeah
yeah they'd launch it you got launched I
don't want to work for ten points okay
no worry I hate episode 6 I believe they
said that they wouldn't give you the
script till the day the day oh yeah yeah
then you find that [ __ ] I was about to
get a raise yeah we figured as soon as
you said that I'm like what do you mean
no he think killed him and I really
believe that I also believe that they're
still there in New Jersey I'm sorry [ __ ]
up
yeah oh right no idea how big [ __ ]
would like she's right people flip that
yeah so he asked for more money they
[ __ ] them something I don't know what
really went on I'm just telling you what
I heard right and at the time ABC had
bought a show called the mezzo fox
called a show called The Meadows about
two gangsters in Hollywood they worked
out of that pink pussycat either they
drove a Cadillac and [ __ ] with
convertible Cadillac and they would
drive the round to the Rita Franklin
will go and drive it on the freeway of
love [ __ ] hilarious so I guess they
signed it bah bah bah the deal didn't
really get developed they weren't ready
for the gay angle uh of two mobsters of
the gay will flip the [ __ ] oh yeah
flip it right and ABC and Fox and forget
it but the guy still kept the rights and
he made a short film and I booked the
short film and she gave it I gave it
Georgie and walking then she sent it to
whatever in New York and next you know I
got a call there's a ticket wait for you
go to New York and read for howl Ramos
and me like an answer I walk through my
hey remember that oh yeah you know
whatever you could have those days at
two thousand two two thousand one two
thousand yeah that was my first one ever
really first whatever how did you book
it I booked it I went for an audition
and got through the first audition and
got a callback and you go into the
callback in midtown Manhattan and this
is my first callback of a film ever you
know and I get there in the
kid comes out and he says okay so you're
gonna read with them you you're next
you're gonna read with Bobby and you
just do the the first scene and we're
just doing the first thing today I said
okay great
I figure Bobby's like you know the the
intern the kid work in the camera and I
walk in and there's Harold Ramis and
Robert DeNiro Bobby oh oh boy okay here
we go
and I start reading it and I'm in awe
I'm gonna be acting great know if it's
if this never gets to live yet to the
movies I'm acting with Robert DeNiro and
I'm in on I start doing it and this son
of a [ __ ]
starts losing his place on the on the
lines and stops in the middle of the
scene and he's mumbling and he's I
didn't know where the next page we are
I'm now I'm like in it I'm like trying
to win this diamond looks yellow he
called me said yeah the Chinese chick
was bangin yeah so I went from wow this
is amazing rabbit and the artist was
killing me okay but then I I booked it I
booked it there was another caterer
who's reading for it too who I knew from
television I had seen him in stuff and I
was like ah so he's gonna get it I guess
that's how it's gonna go and then they I
got it I just couldn't believe it
and I just got that one scene with
DeNiro all day long it was just it was
amaze I read cool he's very famous but
rain Ramos Ramos called me like five
years later out of the blue I'm living
out here now and he calls me and says I
have a great idea for a TV show and I
want you to be the host I'm like all
right whatever it is you're Harold Ramis
whatever it is he said there's when a
pimp pimp my ride was on MTV because I
you know seen that show I want to do a
show called pimp my wife where you take
a couple with and the wife isn't is
appreciated anymore and you dollar up
and you put her in a bar and you makes
the husband watch on camera
how attractive she is to other men and
you see the other man kind of pick her
up and stuff and it rekindles makes him
realize what a valuable beautiful woman
he's married to and reboots the whole
thing and I was like yeah that sounds
pretty good I guess I'll do it and I
never heard from him again
it never happened at that time I was a
little confused about stand up
yeah I was really like I was a regular
at the store the improv would give me
spots once in a while I didn't go to
Montreal like I was like the black
[ __ ] horse yeah he sat there because
I shot you shot in the city yeah I shot
in Kearny oh really I shot right where
they were shooting old Sopranos head and
shot up the corner all night and it was
really interesting because they were
running two cameras at once they were
doing the be scene which was the
barbecue uh-huh and the a camera was me
and Anthony LaPaglia in the beginning ah
and then Anthony would have to [ __ ] him
we take like an hour break if you can't
even have to go change and to barbecue
attire and go over there and I would sit
in the front of this bar this bar was
great yeah always great yeah it was you
know that this WOD nuns bunch a bunch of
the place what the [ __ ] this place we
closed the older Zack I'm sorry sisters
go down the block have a little drink
New Jersey really is a different really
and I wish I was lying no but you know
what's so funny of growing up there like
he says that it makes perfect yeah well
yeah of course of course
yeah hilarious but it was funny because
the wind have gotten out that the Niro
was in the neighborhood oh yeah between
one of those takes the Sun was shining
on me too like Joey got out of the Sun
but let me go to my little [ __ ]
trailer they took me shopping
they took me shopping I'd like to dad
with the Wardrobe they like he too big
we don't have nothing let's go shopping
they took a [ __ ] car and ran my shirt
was 1800 the leather jacket was four oh
my god it's what do the shoes were for
I'm thinking of robbing this [ __ ] had
already the reputation on me
my won in that [ __ ] trailer that ad
was that sure and that's like a congrats
so sure they were watching me but this
is what I felt I'd never met DeNiro
ain't no I went into my trailer and I
sat in the stairs you know he has to get
Eric took my shirt off but I'm like the
Guido look and I'm just sitting there
fat and [ __ ] I'm looking they said
the Destiny Rose trailer you could tell
the American you twice the size of
everybody else across the street had a
be 3,000 people
my little fits yeah they roll like the
Today Show morning Jeff in cops they
were all out there Bobby whatever the
[ __ ] they were saying yeah I don't think
DeNiro heard him but I saw DeNiro the
door walked out some guy walked out the
arrow had that suit on yeah and then she
walked down the stairs there like people
started clapping he looked at them and
he [ __ ] slammed the door he pulled
himself back into the thing really and
then when I went back they said that he
asked to turn the trailer around cuz he
has like social issues like he has
really nice muttering [ __ ] when you were
in the room you ever see him inside the
Actor's Studio
now one of the worst episode he's a
horrible interview he does it right oh
yeah on inside the Actor's shoot you
know like what the guys tell me what you
said to yourself before you walked into
though you know already what do you ask
him before someone I think Conan or
someone like their first show they got
Robert De Niro it was like the biggest
thing and it was the same thing horrible
doesn't like it he has social issues
yeah he doesn't really like to you know
talk he's such a big star I mean he fry
a you know especially growing up where
we grew up the way we grew up my god
come on and then I ran into him like
four years ago like at a party and I was
starstruck I was so starstruck by seeing
him that I forgot we had done a movie
together that's how out of my head I was
at the moment
that's a very tricky guy because yeah my
shot grudge match I went down there the
day early
uh-huh and this is what I notice so
don't feel bad you ready for this I get
there I go to my room I'm rolling John I
go for a walk and I asked one of the
guys where's the setting who's John
today they shoot the two blocks away
just stay on this street walk there so I
walked down there was the gym uh-huh it
was the gym in Louisiana so I walked in
the gym like everybody shook my hand
great to have you're gonna shoot to see
with a low Cool J and deliver Thanks now
the devil comes in all cool I don't say
nothing I'm sitting 60 yards away I'm
watching ya Cool J's hand they hug fist
bump
they talk a little bit they giggle and
then they set up they did the blocking
and you know the blocking was phenomenal
you're a DeNiro was like what the [ __ ]
you mean you're not gonna help me and LL
Cool J is like I'm telling you man I'm
watching that hand I remember this
yeah damn when they put the cameras in
and they said action the first retakes
I love Cujo is a comic [ __ ] yeah cut
ello what's happenin man I just can't
get my worry other way what is up well
Cujo yeah yeah then he picked it up and
then they kept doing it and he finally
got out of it the next day was my turn
to shoot with it ah next I had one scene
with him when he walks in and says
you're my training looks like you ate my
trainer that's that one yeah
now he came in Joe yeah I don't mr.
deverel call me Bobby nice to meet you
sir is my trainer are you doing nice to
meet you I don't say nothing I loved you
this I shut my [ __ ] nobody's but I'll
start with that Guido [ __ ] I saw
king-crab by the neck it's like you're
gonna call sure enough we're talking
he's like uh you really a comedian yeah
it was I like this he was great yeah and
then they go Joe you ready sit down take
the paper and I'm like I got this bit he
walked in the first time I looked at him
so what happened nothing not nothing I
just got overwhelmed you see you see the
guy from Goodfellas yeah that's right
the devil from angel heart
you see mean streets all the face God
fault you just choked right if you want
me to say that I choked the first three
pounds I was like I didn't the second
day he came up this plate light that was
the thing at man boobs yeah and I was
that day was great and then there was
another scene the next day where he had
to call me a fat [ __ ] and he came over
to me goes I'm gonna say fat [ __ ] does
that bother if it ball jungle Channel at
least I got the [ __ ] [ __ ] he is
powerful I mean it's so much history you
saw him at a party and you forgot I had
no problem acting with him acting with
him I was I was fine it wasn't a big
deal he had a woman like his as soon as
this they'd say cut his hair and makeup
lady was on him and like trimming him up
and doing his knee I mean everything and
after every every break cut back
prepping him and I'm just standing there
like an idiot and I'm like how I start
making jokes oh my how's my hair about
my hair wouldn't anyone want to take my
hair my hair and he's like this guy with
his hair this guy really loves his hair
and we had like a good time it was
totally cool I'm at a party he's a New
Year's Eve party he walks in everyone's
all flabbergasted I'm flabbergasted I'm
like that guy I like I wish I had
something to say to him like to break
the ice I get home that night I'm like
wait I was in a movie with it's uh yeah
it's powerful I've never seen Pacino
like I've never seen the nobody else
yeah I mean there I worked a lot James
Coburn made me stunning
oh yeah that [ __ ] yeah he
started just by it like I walked in
there like I was overwhelmed by Diaz
yeah every time I look at him I the
tears in my eyes I thought what a cool
thing that I mean what a cool thing
right to be like bumming around New
Jersey in North Bergen and sinneth
ashore and then like to just have done
one
scene with these guys let alone multiple
stuff I mean that's pretty special
you leave this so crazy so what what the
[ __ ] just happened
yeah you don't make a big deal about it
it's the place close to your heart and
any time a bad thought comes up you
replace that Hey
yeah alright so I came in a minute but
you were phenomenal I've never you know
we bump into each other at the store we
never get a chance to talk about it I
want to talk about it today because he's
always been one of my favorite people
and I'm gonna give you the breakdown
that [ __ ] behind the candelabra you
did yeah
Liberace that is one of the best movies
I did a bit on my CD I loved I think
it's a great you know comedians love
that movie
I [ __ ] adored that yeah I mean
everybody was solid so go ahead let me
tell you so when I was a kid yeah I was
tight with a gay guy that was a
seamstress man in a play in the city you
always tell me about he would always get
invited to bands and all this [ __ ] but
he was a big-time gay guy friends of my
mother they sold coke all right he said
pull the gun one there I'm one of my
friends and I fell in love with him if
you pull the gun even if you guys still
love you you know you're back so we
became friends and I remember being a
kid and telling me about um John Wright
and the Cubans call [ __ ] like really out
there [ __ ] yeah look what a look and look
look and loca like if they're just
regular gay they're mighty Cornus right
but if they're out there go suck 18
dicks with feathers on throw mud Adam
and [ __ ] they're looking right so so I
go did you meet out John yeah you know
he goes local no see I met him in that
local you know like he's like flaming oh
my god but he goes not as loca as
Liberace
I'm Liberace must have done something
Cuba right Liberace was there
what Madonna is to gay people today
right Liberace
like everybody knew Liberace was Gabriel
married yeah and mainstream America did
he first guy my mother was the first
person who told me Rock Hudson was gay
my mother died in 79 right and she's
telling when she was a little girl Cuba
Rock Hudson
it wasn't allowed to [ __ ] men in the
States so he had to go to Cuba so
Ramallah brand no that was their thing
and she would go down random yeah Brando
- we're just talking about yesterday and
there's an article that came because
Brando surprised dick and Brando [ __ ]
the guy and Godfather - with the big
dick in Cuba oh what's this oh I
wouldn't when they go see him and the
guys comes out yeah guys name is the
monster was it Superman yes my Superman
of Cuba and they said there was an
article there's a huge article by a
really biggest fan was Marlon Brando
coming with to showgirls and leave with
him the guy's an 18-inch dick that's dry
he was a man he was a lot more guy in a
date thought and he just [ __ ] women at
the Chinese Theater at night in Cuba
keep saying so many things that are
baffling me oh my god hilarious so
whenever I called my hair weird no he's
not no he's not she's telling me and I'm
like arguing with her like I reminded me
a week can you say that where do you get
balls your balls where do you get balls
to say Rock Hudson's games that I
believe what you wanna believe she died
79 80 yeah it was a big deal sorry ma so
this Martin a mighty Kong guy was
telling me about that nobody does well
Liberace ah
you told me that Liberace came to New
York he was just [ __ ] and jumping like
just [ __ ] and dump was that mean like
just pickin kids just going out just
going up and one-and-done rule one and
done out a check on the way out his 500
there's a gold ring for you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah his own way that Liberace
watch yeah what's so crazy is his
biggest audience was housewives like
they he had a TV show and he plays piano
and it was just anyways be talking to
these housewives through the camera and
they loved him and adored him and had no
idea that he was especially at the time
was living this affluent gay lifestyle
they had no that wouldn't even have
crossed their mind Wow
yeah if you really think about it
Michael Douglas hit
park on there Oh Hammond mad matter hit
it come on out of the [ __ ] arse
so me Michael Douglas has done some
great movies yeah before that you know
what my favorite movie with Michael
Douglas is that nobody knows about a
film called Star Chamber I know now in
1984 him and how him and how Holbrook
Holbrook oh really
there were judges oh yeah Oh nobody
remembers if you haven't seen Star
Chamber yeah look it up guys it's a 1983
movie about judges then if you beat them
in court they send the hit man well I
come get you so if you like let's say
you come in and go Tom papa was arrested
with ten kilos of coke
there's attorney comes in and goes yeah
but the warrants specify the brown house
the house is actually green drop the
charges [ __ ] they would have a
council that night and next thing you
know you're in your room party and some
guy comes and shoots you with a [ __ ]
ball but they weaved it with a Sperry
bat very few bad movies and Michael does
yes
no they we did with a story about a
kidnapping of two kids in a van ah so it
was very well done alcohol I know he
tries to get out Michael Douglas tries
to get out but beside that I mean inside
when he takes his [ __ ] hair off those
boys you know they really they knew it
was a great story and they respected the
story and the characters and just gave
it their all and these guys are just
brilliant actors no it's not a book it
was a book first yeah no actually I
don't think it was a book where'd they
get this information from because the
board maybe what it was the guide Matt's
character I think I think was everything
yeah I think a couple other people yeah
wrote some but that was the 70s when
people will listen to you the studio's
didn't give a [ __ ] now and you know when
he had his own problems and but it was
it was just such a he really died of HIV
correct yeah he was only the first full
of yeah he called it a watermelon
complications from watermelon diet
because nobody was talking about AIDS
but then they dug him up in the book or
something
they did an autopsy and they reveal yeah
I think they do it they say that but
yeah it was hey you know I Soderbergh is
a genius to begin with and and that he
put me in what is one of his favorite
movies that I mean it's one of his
favorites and that I'm in it at all it's
just was would you shoot that great here
shot it here shot it in like Beverly
Hills shot it in Palm Springs shot it
downtown
some jazz club yeah all around here it
was great
he's just a summer class huh you still
go to acting clone now do you want them
are you interested in now me neither
you know I think a big part of the game
is just to be yourself and be confident
and I think we've got that at this point
you know I'm just not I just don't go
audition for a lot of stuff not anymore
they come in no nothing I try to tell
but I know actors that are ready to
shoot them so I you know it's hard it's
I love acting I wish I was in more
movies I wish I was doing more of it but
uh I'm not great at auditioning I don't
look I don't I'm never on my agent like
get me more like I don't know I have to
like get it through people I know or if
stuff I've written myself you know
cherry-pick huh I carry back yeah like
if they send you something and it's like
for a sitcom to play some goofy part you
just say no right
yeah you can't go out for everything
some chick comes it's funny how 20 years
ago view called me and said I have an
audition in San Francisco I'd ride a
bicycle there yeah and the last eight
years after the strike yeah the game
changed so much that you were like you
know what like I started getting calls
it 11 o'clock for 130
producer session I know and I'm like no
prep I'm not doing that right exactly
not doing yeah cause it's gonna be hard
downtown for 30 like they call you 215
right like we're gonna send you the
sides right now just come down and give
it a shot I don't appreciate it but if
you go one time and don't make you do it
again
yeah and so you can't Boston I did all
that stuff you know that kid one
doing you need it for Modern Family and
he said something interesting he goes
Thank You LA I went to all the auditions
even the ones at 4:30 down an ocean down
in sand this place in Santa Monica yeah
where you go to audition like when they
would call you on a Friday huh I said
you had a 3:15 there okay I didn't
[ __ ] heart would stop you're not
coming home until Saturday was two
[ __ ] places that I hate it
yeah that place in Bundy ocean something
and Bundy they were for commercials I'll
never forget going down the Bundy get
taken two hours to get there from
Hollywood on a Friday for a 5:15
audition all they wanted me to do was
put my hands in front of the camera and
then take them out on their way thank
you for coming ah start punching these
movie
guilty at all they call me like they
called me a couple years ago for a TV
show
yeah and this is what happens sometimes
sometimes you have to say no yeah like I
told I'm dying up here didn't call me
like we really want you for this project
on audition it's yours I was like I
don't want to be a [ __ ] Italian
tailor uh you know I'm saying yeah I
know an age now I've been here so long I
just cherry-pick yeah I hear things if
you say something to me I hear things I
see a book I like I really do I find
that it's an option yeah
and I start banging out that way right
right there's a roll in there there's
something I'm working on now
smart that what did hit HBO it's gonna
be tremendous right and I've been
looking at the different angles and I'm
looking for one wrong I know the role I
want they're not gonna give me the
mobsters they're not gonna give me the
Cubans they're not gonna give me the
Jewish roles there's one wrong right and
that's the one I want and I check my
I'll do everything for that role that's
really smart you know I used to send my
own audition tapes it oh yeah like I
used to you would call me no joy at
doing them a few more thousand for 2005
Joey they're doing in my New York movie
with Denzel wash that booked American
Gangster the first turn with tapes I
would get the script from my friend and
I see him long done and I would get the
script if there was three Italian Ross
yeah but the one with the least lines
and I'd send them you
just record on your own record on my own
I pay a buddy of mine he had a house up
here and all the stuff and I do the
whole audition I got into a rhythm of
that that what I wanted yeah that so the
Marines told me a casting director his
job is to get the role booked
right she wants to do it as quick as
possible a sometimes your agent doesn't
have to juice to get you in the room
yeah yeah [ __ ] it I used to overboard
that [ __ ] I used to override that [ __ ] I
would look at the script yeah pick the
least of the sides I want even if there
was a second guy I want right let's go
with this woman might be a [ __ ] pig
right right
go with them you really send the tape
and I would drop it off so listen just
give this to [ __ ] john-boy and you
book through that that way I wouldn't
Adam Sam a longer shot they were like we
won't want big [ __ ] uh Tom Siragusa
Tony Siragusa yeah and I went home and I
ate my and I was in Houston I said first
of all Adam Sandler's had come right
Sara goose and big [ __ ] and great
actors great people but they're not
comics yeah and do Buffalo they've never
done Buffalo they've never done North
Tonawanda that was really my life yeah
they never follow Paul Mooney right
right dirty nights in a row so let me
put it on tape that was my logic so yeah
and that's it it's so smart I know I
mean cuz like the worst thing that could
happen to you as a comic is to get apart
playing a dad in some young girls sitcom
you're not working as a comic anymore
you're invisible to the audience that
wants to see you you're trapped into
this contract with this show we're nope
you're kind of an obscurity you're
working but nobody knows where you are
and nobody knows what you're doing so
why would you chase after that stuff if
you're an actor okay that's the that's
the end game is to get a part in
anything but for comedians you got to be
in the right thing you never wanted to
do a show for six years of ABC and just
call it quits now they gave you a check
out for six years if it was a Tom papa
show offshore
if it was you know if it was us if it
was a sitcom where people are gonna know
hey that's Tom and that thing
they offered me they kept calling me for
this show on the CW they really want you
to play this father on the CW shoots in
Toronto
well why not put me on a cruise ship and
just put a bullet in my head really I
mean what would that do for me it would
it be isolation look if I needed the
money if I if I if I was like really
desperate and but I'm gonna be away from
my family away from my friends away from
comedy just an obscurity doing that
that's not that's the difference between
just an actor and an actor comedian you
know you can't imagine if you had
stopped doing stand-up for the rest of
your days I would never stop you like
you're gone deflating if I well with two
different ages ah you know what you do
in 30 and what you do at 50 is two
different [ __ ] sure how you would
have to treat me on a show now is I tell
you right off the bat first I want to be
shot out first right I'm an old man yeah
that [ __ ] 12 to 12 is not gonna work
right so we're gonna do three takes yeah
at 10 o'clock in the morning I loved you
know you have to know who you have on
the set and what you have on the set
yeah okay I really loved that girl from
saying that live the one that went on to
do 40 rock what's a 13 effect Tina Fey
she gave somebody a chance that is
completely nuts huh but she was a genius
how she used them and you have to when
you have a comic on the set you have to
know the psychology come nope yeah it
bothers me more than a director had you
sitting around for 12 hours looking
medians you got like a three-hour window
that's right and after that you want to
keep us around 288 hours I'm in but
don't put me in three scenes at 8:00
right and then come back to me at 6:00
right that party's gonna be awful was
gone that just doesn't make sense no no
that just does and you're gonna eat
right and you're not gonna get the best
out of the person she would I heard that
she used to Rogan said it works he goes
Roman said if if I have had a show but
Diaz I'm just out off the bat he told me
he goes first I wouldn't want your own
Bob back yeah she would shoot him up
quick wrap around my finger smells like
raping that's that's what they don't
that's when I get pissed off right you
know yeah a comedian they me the
character nothing pisses me off
what compared to the media cactus yeah
gets on the micro yeah I'm not a comedic
actor I'm standing up and that's comedy
right
that's a big difference with a little
bit of formal training yeah did you have
a lot of training no not a lot I mean
all through college I did it did you go
to acting classes in New York ever yeah
I went to HB studios how were they they
were good they were good it just felt
cool to all of a sudden be in New York
and an acting class and then I also went
to this other woman Sheila gray I went
to her for a couple years so I've had
I've had a good amount I guess but I
loved being in New York around other
comedians especially when you're doing
it that way and you realize oh you know
you think it's all gonna be Brando and
you're like I'm as good as these people
I'm all right I can do this this is
gonna be okay and then and then you
learn a lot and I think you know I think
I got to a point where I'm really
confident and can can be myself and do a
really good job I think I'm a good actor
but then watching like Damon and Michael
Douglas when they were doing their thing
in that movie and you're like all right
all the time I've put in as a comic
which makes me really great that way
these guys that they're doing something
at a different level yeah as good as I
think I am and I think oh maybe I don't
need as much training it might be worth
it if you want to be like those guys but
they might also just have a certain
thing that makes them great you know
that's a neat thing and all the time
that they put in but there are a
different level what's the guy
Christopher Walken yeah I heard that
when he did a scene and they yelled cut
the [ __ ] place would applaud Murray
ain't like he would suck you into the
[ __ ] same rides people that you see I
paid their game race that [ __ ]
English guy that played Batman
like I know Christian Bale like when he
played the a donkey on the Irish thing
he's dangerous dangerous level right
those guys I know like we can act
those guys are accident yeah like I
watch a guy like McQueen he's mediocre
Brando let me tell you something man I
watched some of the other night and I'm
very emotional very like when I want
something good that despise me I break
down yeah I cried last night do you see
them they fine that's what I wanted to
be you know I was even possible zoo let
it go for the stress test yeah it's like
you didn't want to eat happy you're
right so I made my wife make me this
pasta fazool and for the rican possible
makes with some grass from the backyard
stuff he put spinach there's no real out
right and I just made a little salad
with blue cheese and lettuce tomato
onions and I made it a point to listen
to the starting five uh-huh like I made
it a point yeah I [ __ ] I was at the
dinner table yeah I wanted to hear where
they were from because the first time I
knew that I could do something yeah was
when I watched the n-c-double-a finals I
was watching Marquette against North
Carolina uh-huh and when they said from
Jersey City New Jersey Michael Coren I
just broke down yeah last night I listen
just to see if they're not amazing if
they had anybody from Jersey yeah that's
every year and the finals I go every
year there's always one [ __ ]
from New Jersey last night there was a
dude from Philly
yes started for Texas Tech or Virginia
and there was a dude from New York well
you could see the dude from New York
there was a kid from Woodland Hills oh
you like [ __ ] cried like I was like
yeah whole thing it means a lot a
Filipino careful
it's great I had a similar thing when I
was a kid I was watching basketball and
it was college game and there was a guy
from my town from Woodcliff Lake and the
same thing I was like ah what I could I
get can I get out he can it he did it
let's go you know it's amazing I'm
emotional too that way it's crazy all
the people that really really came out
like I didn't know Nathan Lane yeah what
some Jersey City what the st. Peter's
Prep well I don't know that what Pink
Floyd tickets at see Jack Nicholson Jack
Nicholson's from Neptune yeah direct you
ever go to Neptune now yeah you know all
those guys you know I was telling uh I
think Tebow and whatever a story about
my eighth grade year when the hottest
basketball playing the country whose
name was Kelly Tripucka
oh yeah yeah and feel ya killed Tony
Soprano hell yeah yeah Kelly if you go
to Denver State and really kill him no
stadium then would them the plays yes
and the ring of favors yeah his father
holds a big beverage company trip yuca
liquor is hell yeah and most basketball
players at the time was scoring a
thousand points in four years right he
was scored a thousand points he was the
next to take a bus we played them in
high school well I took the bus to the
state semifinals to watch him play well
coach Notre Dame was dead you know what
that's why she's was he amazing to watch
at that point like was he he was 20 24
from the field and they made for field
two free throws I know how we beat up we
beat him really because he was the only
guy on this team right right but we'd be
regice on him and he missed a slam dunk
or an alley-oop at the end by just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] head beat him by 100 no
today you play for the piston Wow you
know you see all these people doing I
could do that yeah I know they show you
there's a way [ __ ] do that
yeah we're not that's what different
discipline about college like yeah
in high school they just Christ right
well I want to do is play in the finals
yeah even if I lost right I talk [ __ ]
till the end episode 34 30 about North
Carolina yeah when they do the talk and
they're all sitting around yeah he said
coach said that thank God yeah you could
do whatever you want at that school oh
yeah let's get it whines these [ __ ]
you know you could send your kid for no
collar Oh Europe you got a free pass a
lifetime pass when did you were a
stand-up I wanted to as a kid like in
seventh grade I realized like I was
funny and then I realized like that it
was a job like I heard Steve Martin's
and let's get small and George Carlin's
class clown in one summer and I was like
oh these are grown-ups doing this being
funny for a living I was that from that
point on I was like I want to do that I
want to I want to be a comedian and but
I didn't and I would like record stuff
when I was I had a job as a in college
as a security guard in a housing
development in the winter where I would
just sit in my car
there was nobody coming to this housing
development it was in the middle of like
East Windsor like nothing cornfields and
they're building some houses and I had
to sit in my car in the cold with a
little space heater and I would just sit
out there by myself for hours that was
my job and I would started recording
stand up on a recorder in the car
because I'm by myself going crazy and I
was just you know getting high and this
is talking to myself I started putting
down bits and I bring them back and play
them for my roommates and stuff and they
didn't think they were any good but I
was but then I got out of college and
because I had acted so much I was like
oh maybe I'll win the HB studios and I'm
living in Jersey again I'm living in
Paramus and I'm thinking maybe I'll try
and get parts and it was like he's such
a mind like how do you get a part in
anything I don't have an age I don't
know how did that happen
I was looking to the Village Voice and I
was like oh I don't need permission to
do stand-up it says right here I can go
the New York Comedy Club if I have two
friends it'll buy a ticket and buy the
drinks let's go
Jason Shawn get in the car we're going
june 12th 1993 was my oddity I was in
New York City funny yeah that was my
very first time I was I was electric I
was a I was like oh yeah this is it I'm
doing this this is what I'm gonna do I
walked in greg Giraldo was waiting to go
on and the southern kid was hosting it
was just the three of us and my friends
were the only ones really in the
audience and I met Gerardo and we became
friends like immediately was he all
right
no he wasn't a star yet no he was just
starting who's nervous shaking like a
leaf no beard
just old totally terrified but smart and
funny and we just hit it off and did
that first set you know couple jokes
whatever but it was a rush I'd never
been in a comedy club before that night
you know I'd seen comedy but I'd never
been in a club and just became pals with
him just didn't stop that was it
I just uh I was like oh I don't have to
I can I saw comedy as like you know a
very just part of show business it's
like alright if we walk into these clubs
all of a sudden I'm hosting shows at
Stan of New York and Jon Stewart's on
the show and Brett Butler's on the show
and if as long as I'm funny I can stay
big I can stick around left seemed very
just to me didn't matter who you knew
didn't matter what agent you had it's
just if I can get up on the same stage
as these people and make the people
laugh as much as they're laughing at
them that's all I've got to do I can do
that I could just keep working at doing
that and and that was it I'm gonna go
into Jersey in 90 right after I started
I went to Jersey was 91 I started in
June or July and it was September
[ __ ] Jane wall was already big in the
city yeah
the black kid that's still around from
Jersey from Newark or something Bill
Bellamy Oh Bill Bellamy alum II was
already yeah Rowland cuz I remember
buying one of those newspapers he's
interested but I was such a [ __ ] 91 I
was there for two weeks
oh really and I kept saying I'm gonna go
up I'm gonna go up I never went to such
a [ __ ] and then the second time I came
was January of 93 and right away I
started going over and I met Bob gonzo
Jersey yeah yeah give you $5.00 yeah I
would drive down the show and he'd give
me a fight our bill like and you're
happy and you app happy you were happy
that you got five [ __ ] oh yeah
they're giving me money to do this he
had a room in North Bergen uh-huh
Romano's restaurant all right and at one
time there were like 18 gorillas and he
told me he wasn't gonna go up next thing
they came up with a dog your friends
threatened me kind of put job before
he's like we'll light this place on my
friends always go we all went to see em
fast Harmon Cole had a room yeah his
Secaucus Clifton that's the next clue
yeah yeah yeah yeah your father's up by
from Route three ray exactly could be a
call your father right now that's about
the Clifton drive-in theater oh yeah
that was where I saw five fingers of
death ha ha ha I saw so many movies not
sure my parents were there they were my
dating in high school yeah 3 was yeah if
you didn't want to go to the city or
like North Bergen them whatever I yea
Ivan Clifton by Moonachie I'm gonna ask
you Father how I'll do the people I
never seen people in your life the muna
[Laughter]
they have a tremendous restaurant called
Segovia oh yeah like a Portuguese yeah
all the shrimp is still there I heard
it's still there last time I was there
they asked us to leave there's a place I
was hoping to go down to go to the
Spanish kitchen yeah if you know that
you have you've been there I've been to
that district like yeah I have a place
called the Spanish kitchen yeah think I
took Ramiro go well you know it took me
my kid I suggested next thing you know
what you can st. greasy fight this had
to be a long time a couple years ago
yeah we're uh yeah that's good stuff let
me tell you some pop my love you stand
up I love you
thanks man likewise funniest things a
couple months ago I'm [ __ ] cold man
how is I saw that you like
I don't watch those [ __ ] show yeah me
neither but if I'm scrolling and I see a
friend I tape it and then when I come
back to the store or [ __ ] doing a
potentially yeah I'll watch it yeah and
you were like real subtle and also your
yeah my shows about food what's wrong
we'll eat a piece of bread from time to
time everybody's walking around keto
diet blue mint and they give you that
little Italian bun like a little bun he
had [ __ ] stuck my whole my finger in
it that's what I'm Pablo
yeah man yeah you don't understand why
after thousands of years of heating
bread why we show up and they say it's
bad for you it doesn't make any sense
we've been eating it nourishing
ourselves for this history of mankind
and we show up in 2019 you can eat bread
I'm like something's wrong something's
wrong and then I realized we're not
eating bread we're eating this chemical
concoction that they call bread when I
started baking the bread on my own oh
this is you bacon that's why I made that
for you oh my god thank you I think I
went to a bakery and now I made that
bread for you this morning so when did
you start baking bread how did you get
into this I started it like five
years ago a friend of mine we were
working on a TV show and he was into it
and he started telling me like there's
this natural yeast and the sourdough
starter and that's what they used to
make bread out of and I'm started doing
it and I told my family about it like
this you put flour and water in a but in
a bowl and this yeast goes in and makes
this living organism the sourdough
started you can make bread from it my
daughter for Christmas got one started
for me on the secret she just started
mixing flour and water and got the thing
going and I just started baking it and
real bread is flour water salt and yeast
that is it flour water salt and yeast
anything else is added you're not really
eating real bread and I've been baking
it like crazy
got great at it I started the show on
the Food Network because of it it just
went like wildfire and we eat the spread
all the time and no one's getting fat
from it no one's getting sick no one's
getting fat this is good for you we
should be eating good bread so it's on
cone and I'm like you know I mean I'm
like preaching it everywhere I go I'm
like if you eat real bread you're
allowed to eat real bread you Joey Diaz
are allowed to eat bread don't eat
Frankenstein bread let me ask you this
what do you think about the Italian diet
the Mediterranean diet or the no I'm
talking about just our the way we eat
like Jersey Italian sure I think the
time me and Rogan I've had this
conversation yeah I know it drives me
crazy hey now Italian eating pasta
since Christopher [ __ ] Columbus and
now you want to show up and tell me
carbs and no [ __ ] joke I could see I
know for a tions are the ripped yeah I
was a hot carrier for a summer right and
that guy had to this day I'm emulating
his diet today right he ate five times a
day
uh-huh the only thing I'm not doing that
he does because I'm a [ __ ] is he would
[ __ ] get a little wine glass pour red
wine and saran wrap it and then at
lunchtime he'd take it out no egg but he
lived like 90 Wow I don't touch with his
son until I don't know this is my Jersey
yeah he would eat and then I worked with
a hot Cary North Bergen when I was a
and he would do everything by hand there
was no certificate nothing you had to go
right that guy and we'll severino's his
name is his father lived to be 90 right
and he used to eat you know you can't
eat a [ __ ] bin like this or pasta now
of course a little yeah cup with
marinara meat sauce like a little
meatloaf oh forget the meatball yeah I
don't even need the [ __ ] name well
even even take the meat out of it really
you will I like the marinara you know
what if we're gonna eat let's eat you
understand I was a Cuban kid yeah and
when I came to from the United States
all I want to do is eat white food right
I can when I lived on 205 West 88th
should be only Italian I knew about 100
spaghetti my mother made right which is
Cuban style spaghetti which is delicious
and the pizza joint on 86th and Broadway
and then there was a black guy of my
mother's drycleaners that made spaghetti
and meatballs on Wednesdays and Italian
people in the Bronx will come up and eat
his name is black Mike like Mike Mike
Mike
Mikey black him Mikey white he was the
oppressor at my mother's double does the
cook upstairs for the numbers operation
well when I moved to Jersey I didn't
know I could lie to you people or you I
didn't know nothing about Italian food I
was hooked on that [ __ ] fettuccine
alfredo that now I want to kill kids my
wife loved my daughter was yeah it was
big it was a big no friend in Cuba the
Italians put Lobster on their pizza
right in Cuba was everything was sea
foolishly I don't know what Italian
moved to Cuba but it was very foolish
and when I started I would go John
bender and was the first person who took
me to his house and his mother his
sister was a head kind of a diver and on
Wednesday she would cut hand the living
room and they would make a big bowl of
pasta in the kitchen was what's the
meaning of that they'd be half flying
everywhere
their house I was very Americanized yeah
and her she said to me what's your name
I'm like Coco deers and I would like
just put my head up
yeah we just cuz they were the first
people that ever showed me how to put
polyol rakaat on walking spaghetti which
is a different level I know you have
your spaghetti and meat sauce all you
want yeah once you figure out that for
like put a lump in there mix it up ha ha
oh my god oh my god what is this so
we've caught it be at home bro your mom
is the best you put sausage and meat in
the sauce and then the first time I had
pasta fazool
you know yeah and my dick got hard she
took it out of the freezer with the
spinach in the [ __ ] whatever else is
in there's something else in there it's
got all girl escarole yeah that shit'll
get your dick hard you believe the crack
hos [ __ ] and [ __ ] be possible zoo
I think they test you the next day and
you're fine with that yeah well I just
there's see how old are you and that hit
you then you're like 12 but you know
what you say to me whatever I eat
spaghetti in the house you go
good country America yeah but I mean man
that's in my it's like it's just so much
a part of your of your blood at that
point when you grow up on it and you
know I come out here and there's Monte
Carlos the Pinocchio place on Magnolia
it's like I
if Sunday I this is how I play my comedy
travel if I can fly into Burbank come
home for my shows on Sunday morning I'm
so happy I'm on the plane thinking about
what I'm gonna eat I'm writing down my
list of what I'm gonna do I land at
Burbank get the car drive to Monte Carlo
you walk into this Italian deli the
stuff hanging from the ceiling just got
everything for my childhood is just
around me they've got to give me boxes
to carry the stuff to my trunk you leave
the food what is good now would die me I
get the stuff from the Downers oh my god
I know the food is a question
right it's a lot too sloppy I try to go
to this other place and see you know my
daughter loves it
oh my god I can't say the name cuz
they're nice people yeah every time I go
to have the lentil soup the chopped
salad yeah that's what I'm down to the
pizza if you go to the place over there
you could eat the pizza but we're at the
Monte Carlo our conversations are right
or wrong if the gyro sucks we ain't
moving any further if the pork fried
rice and if the spaghetti sucks we can't
move because I can make a [ __ ] me I'm
a [ __ ] I can make spaghetti with prego
that's better than [ __ ] Pinocchio's
I'm sorry to say their deli section the
deli section is like being in Italy my
wife's like there's having it oh my god
we a little more to sell with the crowd
come on at 2:00 in the morning my what
the Dell booths lied to my daughter we
tell her it's Bologna love it and I just
load up and I go home and I cook and I
want to cook just for the family my
whole Sunday after being on the road is
just get go in get oil in the pan get
garlic and onion going the house has
changed it's filled with something I've
got my bread and I just start cooking
for everybody and that to me is
everything that's that's everything tell
papi a true family man I love you all my
heart is getting [ __ ] hot in here
what date you got coming up my brother
um I'm going to cobs this weekend is
this coming out this week next week next
week just go to town Papa calm you'll
see all my dates I'm pretty much all
over the place I'm kind of at the end of
my tour I'll be shall be winding down in
a little bit do you take time off not
really but like I'll have these runs
where I'm just like going heavy and then
I can't do it and then oh and then I'll
be here doing though I'm gonna at the
store in like a month cuz I've just been
on the road hitting it hard I could do
every other week every other way if you
had a gun too
right yeah go out I don't wanna it's too
too much yeah you'll see as the years
ya know I can feel it last week
Pittsburgh yeah two [ __ ] planes and a
40-minute drive yeah any [ __ ]
chiropractor chiropractic my wife had to
shoot me with a machine gun it's true
put DMV what's that [ __ ] CB deal yeah
you know it's just true I know it is
that next year I'm doing the direct
plane flight don't do a direct flight
tool yeah that's it yeah smart
that's it except for Buffalo but I'm
gonna flying to Kennedy do something and
then fly to Buffalo yeah I can't do that
[ __ ] to the thing and a buffalo JetBlue
you gotta wait to [ __ ] I was it
candidate no I've been on the small
market I want to call it the what are
you doing here to her cuz every time I
see people after the show they're like
what are you doing here and they're hard
to get to the great places but it's hard
to get to yeah Pittsburgh's a great
place it's just hard to get them yeah
man you're the best I always love seeing
you thank you very much thank you for
the bread yes now you now I hope you I'm
gonna dip it in olive oil tonight
ah the one took good I'm gonna dip it
now maybe some olive oil
nice you're done you don't need a meal
you have an open door folks a little
more yes nice oh you could slice that
that's right put a nice [ __ ] egg yolk
on it with butter on the meat toast it I
don't have to tell you what to do
because I [ __ ] scrambled eggs to all
right I want to thank my man Tom papa I
want to thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] on a Monday morning for
spending time with us again I want to
thank our sponsors the church is brought
to you by
manscaped listen there was a long
[ __ ] time ago I told my wife cuz I
can't see I told my wife you got to trim
my around the [ __ ] joystick and I'll
tell you what I had to close my eyes and
pray but guess what because a manscape
those days are over no more [ __ ]
anxiety and your nuts and your dick
could look completely bellissimo you
know I'm sayin I gotta go International
today don't cut your dick off [ __ ] oh
the suffering ends now why
I'm gonna get you through this with
manscaped you could get it done without
the pain without the anxiety they got
precision tools for you
your family jewels okay manscape this
redesigned the electric razor
the invention their invention is the
lawnmower
a handheld razor with skin-safe
technology so it won't Nick or snag your
nutsack you got to go easy on what the
Lord gave you this bad boy will leave
you clean smooth and pain-free plus it's
rechargeable easy to hold get into all
those nooks and [ __ ] crannies
especially your chubby [ __ ] like me
manscape you'll get your bean bag
looking as smooth as a [ __ ] egg I'm
gonna tell you a little secret if you
trim the hedges the tree looks a lot
[ __ ] bigger you understand me trim up
that [ __ ] that grow at manscape calm
you get everything you need to make your
ball shine and you dick look [ __ ]
spectacular and for the first time if
you've considered manscape and they got
a deal for you you're ready they got the
perfect package which comes with a lawn
mower and a safety razor plus plus the
crop Reserve especially formulated
deodorant so your balls don't stink and
a spritz that tones and refreshes your
junk to keep it cool listen the church
family can get 20% off your first order
when you use promo code church at
manscape calm again if you get the
perfect package forget about it don't
throw in a free travel bag that's
tremendous I got one in my suitcase
right now as we struck its peak just use
promo code Church throw to manscape
dot-com use promo code church for 20%
off your first order right you got to
keep your balls clean everybody wants to
fall in love but nobody got clean balls
number two I want to thank CBD Lyon
commerce and the search is over
CBD gonna simply be lying calm go to the
website and just read the first hand the
third party test results see what the
hell they're about listen I live and die
by CBD line detention twice three kinds
of them a fat [ __ ] the gummies after I
work out listen if you want a smoke shot
and the vapor pen comes at different
colors so you know what you're treating
when it comes to the CBD CBD line
there's the one for you go to CBD
line.com right now
in church and get 20% off I also want to
thank on it audit comm has been there
for us since day one the supplements
Aubrey goes all the way around the world
looking for the best supplements for you
all right so I want to thank manscape I
want to thank on it and I want to thank
CBD line but most importantly I want to
thank you [ __ ] for listening
and giving us this shot I got no dates
on the books it's over
I'm shooting movies I'm smoking cigars
I'm slinging dick and I suggest you do
the same
have a great week and we'll see you
Thursday you little dirty bastards
stay black uncle Joey loves you check
this [ __ ] mealy